[Music]
several observers were actively engaged
in the protest
these people are were antagonizing and
obstructing our officers Metro Sheriff
Jill and barter there we brought you
that press conference live yesterday at
noon here on Eaton is now as the sheriff
addressed protests last Saturday on this
trip and specifically several legal
observers who were detained that's been
something of a controversy since that
happened last weekend this morning for
morning cup of joe were actually joined
by Metro captain Dorie Koren for morning
cup of joe segment thank you sir for
joining us that we've got the
technological issues worked out
we have several topics to discuss but
first sir you're with the convention
center area command that includes the
Las Vegas Strip that's where this
happened over the weekend why was it
necessary to detain those legal
observers well first of all let me first
say good morning definitely appreciate
you guys having us on the show this
morning as you said I'm captain Dorie
corn and responsible for convention
center Area Command that covers the
majority of the strip from basically
Sarah to Russell I ask your viewers to
bear with us we're having a little bit
of a technical challenge so we're using
a mobile phone to make this work so um
but just to uh briefly answer your
question sheriff Lombardo held a press
conference yesterday it was about almost
30 minutes very informative I would ask
your viewers to really refer to that
because the sheriff answer that question
a lot of other questions in a lot better
detail than I can this morning I can
just only add that as a sheriff has
indicated before we definitely respect
everyone's First Amendment rights and
any other constitutionally protected
rights and we're there to protect that
just as much as we are to protect this
community and protect the officers that
serve the community but I definitely
refer your your viewers to that press
conference because they'll be able to
get a lot of their questions answered by
simply looking at that and you can you
can visit the lv MPD youtube site and
you can access that press conference
pretty easily and during that press
conference the sheriff shows some of
that video we were just showing
including several incidents with the
legal observers in some cases
obstructing some officers and
antagonizing some officers and speaking
of that captain can we ask you just
broadly how Metro prepares for staffing
protests we've had about 90 in recent
weeks as a sheriff indicated last
night during the press conference we've
had a considerable amount of protest
events but we have a good system in
place to be able to make sure that we
have enough officers to keep the
community safe and as I indicated
earlier the the press conference really
goes into a lot of details and it's best
I think for the community here from the
head law enforcement person and are
really in Southern Nevada so I refer for
those questions I think it's best coming
from him I definitely don't want to
confuse the issue by answering it
inappropriately if I don't have all the
information right now the most informed
person on it is our Sheriff well captain
it's been almost two weeks since the Las
Vegas Strip reopened Metro Police was on
this trip even when the casinos were
closed
how was Metro involved in getting all
the different properties back open again
safely sure so we we have an incredible
private public partnership with all of
our partners all along the strip and
really throughout the valley we're
really truly blessed in terms of how we
work with our partners before koga 19
which was certainly unprecedented cause
some things that none of us could have
ever expected including shutting down
the entire Las Vegas Strip we worked
very closely with all of the partners
both small and large and ultimately we
held several different teleconference
calls to keep it safe so that way we're
not in the same room together
we did something called state of the
strip on every every month or so we held
the teleconference call with almost a
hundred different community partners and
business partners that are responsible
for keeping the strip safe but also
effective in terms of being an economy
for this entire state so we held the
teleconference the state of the strip
teleconference call as often as we could
with all of our partners so we could
communicate what they needed from us to
either complete the shutdowns and then
now that we have reopened we've done the
same thing we've communicated with them
very closely to see what they need from
us to prepare for their reopening
unfortunately now that it's already been
two weeks
I think Vegas is definitely going in the
right direction we are open again people
are visiting us again
the local community is coming out and
we're doing it as safely as we possibly
can yeah I was on the strip last weekend
noticed a lot less people out for now so
captain are there less officers
patrolling the strip and is there
anything in particular officers are
looking for right now
so Las Vegas or excuse me I'm sorry
Convention Center Area Command is one of
our largest area commands and that's by
design because we're responsible for one
of the most populated areas in Southern
Nevada which is the Las Vegas Strip so
we have considerably the most amount of
officers a sign of that Area Command for
that reason now I can tell you the when
Kogut 19 began that pandemic started
causing global issues we maintain the
same amount of officers in that area
command because we didn't want to do
anything that would compromise the Las
Vegas Strip
so even if people were vacating it
because we were shutting it down we
couldn't afford for it to be damaged to
the point where would be hard to reopen
so we maintained enough of a security
presence to ensure that everything
remains safe and that we would be able
to quickly reopen and that's exactly
what happened so we're the only
exception of that is crime was displaced
to some extent when we shut down crime
was dropped significantly because
obviously there was a lot less people on
the boulevard when it was closed and
there was increasingly the crime
increase in other areas our our Area
Command officers did assist on the
borders could have epson Area Command we
also sent some of our officers to go
assist in some high crime areas but
beyond that we try to maintain a
significant presence on the strip
because we promised our community that
when the time was right when the
governor decided to open or reopen that
we'd be ready to do so with little to no
time on our part and that's exactly what
happened as soon as it was announced
with short notice that we were ready to
reopen and our strip partners told us
that they were going to open we were
able to keep the entire boulevard safe
clean and ready to go as soon as we got
that board well captain very quickly
bring a little bit short on time when
the pandemic was in its throes and
everything was closed
I saw we all saw all the cyclists up and
down the Las Vegas Strip now the things
are open can people still do that you
know there's still some cyclists but
we're seeing some return of normalcy and
I think it's important for your viewers
to know that fortunately Vegas is
starting to come back and so I've asked
my officers and they're saying that
there's still some cyclists but really
we're seeing cars and pedestrians and
people starting to visit our hotels and
that's what I encourage everyone in our
community as to as long as it's safe to
do so it's time to get our economy as
strong as possible and definitely I
think our community needs that right now
absolutely
all right captain Corrin thanks so much
for your time this morning please stay
safe out there we appreciate you joining
thank you appreciate it as well thank
you for the invitation all right you can
watch every morning cup of joe segment
Wednesday's here on 8 news now if you
have questions for sheriff Lombardo
submit them on our website 8 News
now.com at 6:52 here's Nate Tannenbaum